is Adsense a viable business model I'm
going to answer that question in today's
episode of ask Evan
so I'm Lisa got a question for one of my
loyal YouTube followers love you guys
Caleta who wrote in this a question do
you suggest having adsense connected to
your blog if I'm selling a product and
why so there's a fantastic question I'm
gonna share with you my three tips to
consider before you set up adsense on
your blog number one is you get paid for
clicks and it depends on your niche so
you have to remember that for most
Adsense on blogs you get paid for when
somebody clicks on your advertisement
there is some advertising we get paid
just on the number of views but for the
most part you'll get paid when somebody
clicks and so it highly depends on the
market that you're in so for example if
you're selling recipes or if you're in
the cooking industry the clips aren't
very high so you could begin a lot of
people clicking on your ads but you
won't be making a lot of money because
there's not a lot of advertisers there
but if you're in another industry like
insurance or selling leads for people
then the clicks are a lot higher and you
can make a lot more money so understand
that's all about how many clicks you can
get on those ads and what meats you're
in and if it's going to be profitable
for you or not number two is it's best
for high traffic and new visitors
so the advertising model works really
well when you have a lot of people
coming to your website and they're all
new visitors because they don't know
where the ads are and they're more
likely to click on it if you have a lot
of repeat visitors coming they know
where the ads are they have what's
called banner blindness and they're not
going to click through on your
advertisement so you have to look at
your traffic are the repeat visitors
people are coming back over and over
again or are they a lot of new people
coming for the very first time and you
have to figure out how to ramp up your
content to get hundreds of thousands and
millions of people coming to your
website to make it worthwhile from an
Adsense point of view and number three
products are best for repeat blog
traffic so if you have a lot of people
coming back to your web site over and
over and over and over and over again
your developer in a relationship with
them and so the downside is they're
probably not going to click on the
advertisement because they know where
they are but they know you they like you
they trust you they're coming back
repeatedly and they're much more likely
to then buy your
subscribe to your newsletter do
something that they feel is personal to
you because they've invested in yourself
so if you are dealing with a lot of
people who have never visited your site
before and there are always new people
you want to go the advertising route if
you're dealing with a smaller base and
it's a lot of repeat visitors and you
want to go the product route so thank
you for the question Caleta I hope that
helped you and for everybody watching
I'd love to know if you are running with
that adsense model advertising model or
if you're running with a product based
model leave it in the comments below and
of course if you have a question for me
that you want me to answer in the next
ask Evan segment leave it below and I'll
see what I can do thank you so much for
watching you continue to believe and
I'll see you soon